I've never said that there's a
one-size-fits-all approach and you know
people have character I mischaracterized
my view is that everyone should drop out
of college everyone should start a
company I don't think everybody should
be starting companies you know just
given this power law thing I think a lot
of companies don't work we need more
people to start good companies but but I
think also the sort of super tract
dynamics have have gotten us to to a
very bad place where where education has
become a substitute for thinking about
the future you know and the K through 12
system is geared towards college on and
the problem is
life doesn't end in college you know it
you know hopefully you live for a long
time after that and do many many things
after college and and and there's a
strange way where we live in a society
where there's a lot of anxiety about the
future and we put more and more money
into education for the last 35 years as
a way of dealing with this anxiety where
if you get into the right College
you know you'll be saved if you don't
you're in trouble I sort of described
the college so dramatic version I've
said is you know colleges they're like
there's corrupt as the Catholic Church
was five hundred years ago they're sort
of charging people more and more it's
the system of indulgences you have this
priestly or professorial class that
doesn't do very much work and then and
then you basically tell people that if
you get a diploma you're saved you know
otherwise you go to hell you know you go
to Yale or you go to jail that's sort of
the that's sort of and and what I think
we need to we need to push back on on
this on this that this this idea that
the only way you get saved is you know
Catholic Church five hundred years ago
or today the only way to get saved is by
by getting a diploma from college and I
hope I hope that in the future there
will be many different kinds of
productive things for people to do my
goal the teal fellowship was not to
start a new church the startup church or
something like that
it's not to have this alternate
one-size-fits-all thing but I think the
future system will be one that's much
more heterogeneous and will be
many more ways for people to be
successful maybe your flying cars will
save us all
again I look I think would be good to
have flying we having a wave our tagline
on our website they promised us flying
cars and all we got was 140 characters
not against Twitter on but but but look
it's it would be good to have flying
cars be good to have many other things
but there's no you know I the claim is
not that if we have flying cars that's
going to save us all we need to be doing
more in many dimensions including you
know repairing the the entire financial
system from from ground up Peter teal
everybody thank you so much Emily thanks
what Hey